lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
nos familiaricemos con la idea de tratar
las unidades como variables algebraicas
tomemos una de las fórmulas más
conocidas distancia es igual a rapidez
por tiempo digamos que la rapidez está
en términos de kilómetros por hora por
ejemplo no sé se me ocurre en 10
kilómetros por hora y el tiempo está en
horas por lo que no sé se me ocurre que
sea que sean dos horas lo genial de esto
es que puedo tratar a las unidades como
variables algebraicas primero veamos la
parte numérica esto va a ser igual a 10
por 2 10 por 2 y ahora veamos las
unidades esto lo voy a tener x
kilómetros por hora por estas unidades
de aquí que son horas si tratamos a
estos kilómetros que sabemos que es una
unidad de distancia y son mil metros sin
embargo si esto lo tratamos como una
variable algebraica cualquiera igual que
h entonces puedo hacer esto
quitar esta hora con esta hora y dejar
solamente los kilómetros de manera que
me queda 10 por 2 va a ser igual a 20 y
la unidad que me queda es km lo que está
bien porque km es una unidad de
distancia así que nuestra distancia está
bien que tenga estas unidades veamos
otro ejemplo ahora en lugar de tener
kilómetros por ahora nos dan la rapidez
en kilómetros por segundo
aquí nos dan no sea igual que sean diez
kilómetros por segundo y esto es
bastante rápido y el tiempo nos lo dan
en horas en este caso vamos a tener tres
horas si multiplicamos 10 por 3
tendríamos 30 pero las unidades nos
quedarían en kilómetros por hora entre
segundo que es algo bastante extraño si
esto hiciera la multiplicación tal cual
me quedaría 10 por 330 kilómetros por
segundo y por hora que esto es una mira
bastante bizarra
lo que quiero hacer es quitar esta hora
y este segundo como lo puedo hacer si
tratamos a esto como variables
algebraicas tengo que multiplicar esto
por algo que tenga segundos en el
numerador y tenga horas en el
denominador pero no puedo hacer una
multiplicación asia arbitraria tengo que
multiplicarlo por algo que tenga sentido
por ejemplo qué tal si multiplicó por el
número de segundos que hay en una hora
yo sé que en una hora en una hora hay
3600 segundos tiene de que una hora
tiene 60 minutos y cada minuto tiene 60
segundos si multiplico 60 por 60 me va a
dar 3600 estos son los segundos que hay
en una hora es una unidad por lo que no
voy a estar cambiando el valor de este
veámoslo más explícitamente quedamos que
hay 3600 segundos en una hora qué pasa
si yo divido ambos lados entre una hora
3600 segundos entre una hora esto es
igual a una hora entre una hora
pues esto es igual a un entero esto
también va a ser igual a 1 por lo que
esto es 1 esto es multiplicando todo
esto por 1 y no le estoy cambiando lo
estoy afectando estoy haciendo esta
multiplicación y ahora sí siguiendo con
lo que estamos diciendo de que podemos
tratar estas unidades como variables
algebraicas estas horas se van estos
segundos se van y me quedan las unidades
de kilómetros y pues tengo que
multiplicar los valores numéricos aquí
bueno si yo multiplico 30 por 3600 me va
a quedar bueno no olvidemos que esto es
distancia y esta distancia va a ser
igual a tengo un cero aquí otros dos
ceros acá puedo poner acá mis tres ceros
y ahora multiplico tres por 6 18 llevo
13 por 3 91 que llevo son 10
tengo 108 mil kilómetros que es la
unidad que me quedó 108 mil kilómetros
lo importante aquí es que primero esto
lo van a usar en física en química y en
él
de su vida segundo con esto podemos
manipular las unidades como variables
algebraicas lo que es tremendamente útil
para revisar errores para convertir las
unidades finales de una operación e
incluso cuando nos enfrentamos a
ecuaciones complejas esto nos sirve para
comprender de qué tratan las diferentes
variables existentes en dicha ecuación